firstly we backed off I what is meant by
shared storage also known as external
storage shed storage is the area of apps
can write files visible to other apps
once they get granted the reader write
external storage permission functions
that return locations within shared
storage include get external files days
which returns your apps files folder get
external cached ears which returns your
apps cache file folders and get external
media dears the returns your apps media
folders game developers may also be
interested in the OEB directories
returned by ghetto BB dears now let's
dive down into what's with storage
situation is like currently on Android
PI on one hand we have internal storage
which is private to your app meaning
apps will never be able to access
meaning other apps will never be able to
access data their internal storage is
thus a good place for internal app data
that the user doesn't need to directly
access and on the other hand we have
shared storage that we just talked about
it is a world we double space that can
be viewed and modified by the user and
apps this is what you see when you
enable USB mass-storage
and plug your phone into a computer to
see files in slash in shared storage or
slashes D card apps need with storage
permission for files written there
there is no app to file attribution
there's our one exception shared storage
contains app attributed directories but
do not need any permission to be
accessed by the owner app these include
with directories returned by the kik
external files media and cache dear
functions new permissions are needed
since these folders have a clear app to
fall ownership structure this ownership
structure ensures that files are cleaned
on a fuelling store so that was a
situation in Android P storage is one of
the most popular permissions used by
Android apps and as a result we've seen
apps behind in all kind of ways with
issues issues such as disk clutter in
android q we looked at how we could
improve shared storage by abiding to
three principles that improve the
experience for users
the first one is better attribution here
we're really trying to solve clutter by
avoiding files lingering around on disk
once an app is you'll installed so in
queue
we're ensuring the system knows what
files belong to what apps this makes it
easier for users to manage their files
and means that when the app is you
installed both content a rotary disk is
cleaned up after there's obviously
always content but user will want to
persist post unis store and we'll talk
about this later
the second principle is protecting app
data when app swipes files to external
storage it should not be made freely
available and visible to other apps you
don't want other apps looking into what
your app is doing so in queue we're
protecting the app specific data but
disallowing other apps to view this
content and the third principle is
protecting user data when you download
files such as pictures in your private
conversations or PDF of your bank
statements you probably don't want all
apps to immediately see these files and
glean info about your behavior in queue
we're making sure users know when and
what files apps are accessing so by
sticking to these principles we do stick
nice prints or means that we are doing
deep changes in the way storage works on
Android and we understand it may take
some time for apps to adapt to these
changes but we think that in the long
term this will help me Android a better
platform for users by providing better
privacy and storage management so with
this in mind let's have a look at how
storage will work in android q so in
Android q we're doubling down on media
store the first change is apps can
contribute to media store without any
permission however to view content
contributed by other apps the storage
permission is required apps can
contribute can continue to read and
write to their specific directories but
other apps even if they have obtained
the storage permission cannot view them
unless we date the files are attributed
to one
apps will still be able to pick files
present anywhere on disk using the
system picker which gives the app a tree
which gives the app and user a
transactional approach to getting access
to a file this makes access more secure
since it makes it more explicit to the
user what file or files are being
accessed the final thing to mention is
the way that internal storage is not
changing in queue so we see that media
store is not new to Android in fact it's
been here since day one by Android queue
we're doubling down on media store and
improving it so let's look more into how
it works so first questions what belongs
in media store Modesto is designed to
hold content that belongs to the user
and that is available to other apps thus
we'd recommend only constituting files
when the user actively expects it to be
actually as we expects it to be present
in its video store collections such as
them explicitly taking a picture in the
camera app the main types of media
present in media store are audio video
and images so content contributed to mr.
persist post app Yunnan store however
once the app is unistall the content is
considered to be orphaned and if the
same app is then reinstalled later it
will need to obtain the storage motion
from the user to see content that it had
previously contributed now what does not
belong in meet the store this is a bit
more nuanced since this is more about
user expectations but sometimes it's
pretty obvious what does it belong at
specific media like thumbnails album art
or stickers would usually not be
appropriate for media store since there
are lot of files user would want to see
in other apps or see persist post
afternoon in store in some cases you may
not you may think it's like you may not
be sure whether content belongs for
example users in chat apps may exchange
a large amount of pictures that would
create clutter in media store in these
situations we suggest not contribute to
be just or straight away but wait until
I use
has taken an explicit action such as
selecting save now in and ruku we're
introducing a new collection restore
which is the Downers collections and
this one works a bit differently
remember previous free that we mentioned
this collation is to place files that
don't fit into other collections such as
PDF files or any other type of documents
you can also contribute content there
that would go into other collections if
you want it to be explicitly part of a
downloads collation in that case it will
also be automatic contributed to the
other appropriate collection so for
example if you download a photo in your
web browser and add it to the downloads
collection it will also be added to the
images collection so like the previous
mentioned collections that's can view
over content Lee contributed however to
view files contributed by other apps a
system picker invoked by action over
document for example is required to be
used another tip is to not always
contribute data to a damaged collection
especially when the user might want to
control their where it's stored such as
saving a document in this case launching
ash and create documents intent is
recommended it lets users choose any
local network or cloud storage provider
occasion so this was a quick overview of
like how many store works and I'm going
to hand over to Jeff he'll give you more
details of how to contribute and query
me the store you think thanks AB
[Applause]
so as sub mentioned one of the big
changes that we're making in the kirilus
is we're giving you developers the
opportunity to contribute items to media
store without needing the storage
permission you can now insert modify and
delete any Content that you own
yourselves into media store only when
you want to work with content that has
been contributed by other applications
do you need the storage runtime
permission we think this is going to be
a great change for apps like photo or
our camera apps because you don't need
the storage permission anymore you can
capture that image and then save it into
media store and you won't need that
runtime permission as sub also mentioned
things that you contribute to these
common collections it's your way of
saying this content belongs to the user
and it's intended to persist beyond the
lifetime of your application so if the
user uninstalls your app that data is
going to be preserved so let's take a
look at example of how this works in
practice with some code as Seb mentioned
media store has been around since
Android 1.0 so some of the api's that
you're seeing on screen you've already
been working with today I'll focus on a
handful of places we've added new
special behaviors that can help make it
a better experience
so here the code sample on the slide
we're creating a Content values to
contribute a new image that we're
working with in the Q release all we
need to do is specify the display name
and the mime type of the content we're
working with in this case it's just an
image JPEG image the new thing that's
highlighted on screen here this is a new
feature in the Q release the is pending
flag when you insert an item by do when
you insert an item that is marked as
pending by default it will be hidden
from other applications on the device
when they go query media stored they're
not going to see that item that's
pending there this gives you as the
developer a way to temporarily work on
that item until you're ready to reveal
it to other apps on the device an
example here might be if you're a web
browser working on a long-running
download where you may switch between
mobile and Wi-Fi networks you can insert
that item that downloaded item market is
pending you can slowly work maybe over
15 to 20 minutes however long it takes
to download that item and once you're
finished
when you can set that is pending bat
back bit back to zero to reveal it to
other applications on the device so back
to our example here we have our content
values inserting something that's
pending I down below we have our content
resolver
and we're going to be working with the
primary external storage volume content
resolver insert you've probably already
been using that today this is what's
going to insert a record to say that you
want to work on this item it's reserving
a space for you to insert now that we
have that item we call as the result of
that insert call was a new specific URI
that has been allocated just for you to
work on that item with that URI that
item URI you can now open a file
descriptor in this case for write access
here and you can stream contents into
place
so we've alighted some of the details
here if you need to you can also you can
do that up in managed code in Java you
can also use that file descriptor to go
across J&I and contribute data if you
have native code in your application at
some point we'll be finished with the
file descriptor we'll close it and now
it's time to reveal that to the other
apps on the device and that's as simple
as clearing out that content values
setting the is pending bit to zero and
then calling content resolver dot update
once you make this call that's going to
cause it to become visible to the other
apps on the device so that was a simple
example let's look at some more complex
ways some new features that we've given
to you to work with in media store you
now have the ability to influence
directories of where things are stored
on these external storage devices in the
simple example that we just looked at a
few moments ago the operating system
automatically picks a safe default
location because we were inserting an
image slash JPEG object the OS will put
it in the pictures directory by default
similarly if we were inserting say an
audio type of file format we would be
automatically inserted into the music
directory on the device so we're helping
set some good defaults but you also have
the ability to influence if you want a
specific directory and this is the new
relative path column which is part of
the part of the public API you can set
this value to control where those files
are placed on disk
we'll give an example of that in just a
moment
similar to I these two columns both the
relative path and the display name you
can use them when you're inserting
content but you can also use them later
on once you publish content if you need
to move it around on disk you can call
content resolver to update with those
columns and the OS will now move the
content on disk on your behalf so
zooming out a little bit more we've
talked about influencing directories of
where the content lands in queue we've
also given you more capabilities to
control which storage device it lands on
this is particularly useful for Android
devices have that have multiple shared
storage locations they may have a built
in shared storage but they also may have
an SD card slot where the user has
inserted something starting in queue you
now have the flexibility to control
which device you want that content to
land on earlier we mentioned the volume
external primary that's the volume name
of that primary storage device um you
can also call a new API get external
volume names and this will enumerate all
of the possible storage locations that
is a ver that are available for your
application to use once you've selected
one of those volume names it's easy to
start working with that collection using
the various get content URI methods that
you'll find across the collections in
media store so if we pick a secondary
storage device if we discover it we can
go past that as the argument to the get
content your I say for example for the
images collection that will allow us to
work with images that are present on
that secondary the storage device such
as an SD card so let's took a take a
look at an example of both of these
advanced concepts together in one one
example so the first thing we talked
about was that relative path being able
to influence where things land on disk
here we have a simple music file that
we're inserting my song mp3 um the
relative path here we're asking for it
to be placed under music my artists my
album something worth noticing to call
back to a subs point that he made
earlier one of our goals in queue is to
help ensure that the users content
content is organized on their device and
so what this means that top-level
directory we're going to help make sure
that it's placed in a reasonable
location so here we're inserting an mp3
file an audio file into the music
directory the top-level directory the OS
is going to allow this because the
content type makes sense
if for example we were trying to insert
this mp3 file into the users pictures
collection that doesn't make sense
that's disorganized and so the OS would
throw an exception back to you so just
those three common collection types that
we discussed audio video and images
there's a handful of locations top-level
directories that are allowed for each of
those you can find in the developer
documentation more details but it's our
way of helping keep the users content
organized all right so in this example
that relative path selected music my
artist my album just like we did before
we're gonna use insert but the second
half of the slide this is where we're
going to select a specific a secondary
storage device we're seeing what volume
names are available and the ellipses
there it's up to you in your application
but you could go and prompt the user to
select one of those storage devices that
are available or you could have settings
deep inside of your application where
you let the user pivot and choose one of
those locations one of those storage
devices either way when you've made your
selection here's where you pass that
volume name into the get content URI and
this is what's going to allow us to work
with the audio collection on a specific
storage device and then the final call
will actually insert that and work with
it so we talked about quite a bit about
contributing the content let's shift
gears and talk about discovery if you'd
like to consume the content or list it
or display it to the user
thankfully the api's you've been working
with today content resolver query those
will continue to work with these
collection types so you can query find
items in the users images or music
collection um the one thing we're
changing in the key release we're
strongly recommending that you switch to
using content resolver dot open file
descriptor when you want to work with
one of those particular items in and the
reason is the data column which has been
there for many years has now been
deprecated and we'll get into a little
bit more later today on why that's
difficut
but the best practice that we're
encouraging developers to move towards
is using open file descriptor in
you'll get back a parcel file descriptor
be able to send that either to manage or
down to native code so it's quite
flexible as we mentioned earlier by
default applications that query this
collection
they won't see any pending items that
other applications are still working on
if you find yourself if users expect to
see those pending items in your
application you can still modify the URI
that you're about to query to request
that those pending items be included one
thing to note is that for each of the
items that is being contributed we now
track who contributed it who the owner
is of those items what this means is
well an item is pending only the owner
of that item can work with the content
they're the only ones that can read or
write the contents of the file only when
they've published it when you've cleared
that pending flag is it available for
other applications to see the reason
that's relevant here for the set include
pending you'll be able to see that other
people are about to contribute items you
won't be able to open those items until
they've been published because they're
still under construction here's an
example of how to use these things in
practice so uh here we have a normal
collection the users a video collection
URI that we've gotten our get content
URI from that but in our case we'd like
to see some of that pending content the
set include pending we pass in the URI
and we get back a slightly modified
version of that URI it's modified to
tell us as the OS that you'd also like
to see the pending items once you've run
a query with a cursor that comes back
that gives you the opportunity to show
those items to the user and pick one to
work with open file descriptors another
great choice here for a specific item
that you found with that parcel file
descriptor that comes back many of our
utilities across the OS whether it's
image decoder or our other media player
API is they're ready and willing to
accept that filed that parcel file
descriptor finally one side note at the
bottom of the slide there's a new API in
queue content resolver dot load
thumbnail and this is designed to
provide an optimized path for loading a
small lightweight thumbnail in your app
you can imagine if you're scrolling
through a large list of contents you
don't want to open the large heavyweight
items just to generate a small thumbnail
to show to the user so this new load
thumbnail API for a specific item you
pass in the item you're interested in
and the size roughly the dimensions on
screen that you're looking to show to
the user internally in the OS will do
the hard work of helping resize that
image to make it nice and lightweight
and will also handle caching that so
that we ensure that it's fast for you to
reopen in the future and will also
handle if the content has changed over
time will automatically invalidate that
thumbnail and regenerate it so it's
designed as a great best practice API to
use if you want to just show lightweight
thumbnails so now that we've discovered
items let's talk about editing items a
change that we're making in the key
release we've already described items
that you contribute you have full
read/write and delete access to the
items that you have contributed
however items that belong to other
applications you won't you'll only have
read access to if you'd like to be able
to modify or write those items you'll
need to involve the user and we're doing
this any of the operations on content
resolver that work with modifying files
whether it's update delete or opening a
file descriptor for the write mode all
of those they will check internally if
you have the right permission to that
item if you don't have the permission
it'll throw back a new type of exception
a recoverable security exception well
dig into a moment an example of what
this looks like the easiest thing when
you receive one of these it's telling
you it's an exception you don't have
access now but if you involve the user
the user is able to grant you that
access so that you can have both read
and write access let's take a look at an
example here at the top we're trying
we're attempting to delete a specific
photo but we don't know we don't have to
know ahead of time if we have that
permission or not if we have the
permission the delete will succeed if we
don't it'll throw that recoverable
security exception back at us and it's
up to us to involve the user and
whatever way is most appropriate in this
example on the code slide we're going to
be showing an alert dialog to the user
in our application on this alert dialog
when the user presses the button we're
going to launch that pending intent
that's included in that
exception which is going to show a
dialogue to the user letting them grant
that access to your application for that
specific item that you're interested in
so we get that exception there's a nice
message under user action it has a title
and there's also that pending intent
that action item or that action intent
is a pending intent that you can send to
involve the user the alert dialog is
just one example here for the purposes
of our presentation today but depending
on the design of your application you
may also want to show a notification to
the user if you're trying to do this in
the background there's many ways to get
the user to launch to launch the pending
intent so that it's quite flexible in
letting you figure out the best way to
involve the user so shifting gears a
little bit more one thing we're focusing
on in queue is helping protect location
metadata as Seb mentioned one of the
critical features we're building a queue
is helping protect users privacy and
security and what this means is normally
when you go interact with an image file
we will be redacting any location
information included such as the
latitude or longitude in the exif
metadata so if you find yourself if
users expect to see the location
information inside of your app you can
add a new permission access media
location to your manifest this will
allow you when you open that file we
will not redact the information it will
allow you to see the full latitude
longitude but what we're doing it's by
default we're protecting that
information you'll still be able to see
the other exif metadata such as the
shutter length of shutter speed other
information about the date time taken
but only the location data is going to
be redacted on media store there are two
columns latitude and longitude that in
previous releases have been indexed
now in the key release you'll find that
those columns are null and they're empty
instead if you need access to that the
location metadata you can use the exif
interface tool instead let's take a look
at this in action so in this case if
your app actually needs in for access to
that location information if the user
expects it you would just add a user's
permission tag to your manifest
note that the this is not a runtime
permission it's purely a signal signal
to us or the OS that you're interested
in to this information simply by adding
it it will grant you that access so by
virtue of requesting that information
that that permission when you go to open
in this case the open input stream for a
particular photo you can pass that into
the exif interface that's a class that's
been in the OS for a couple years but
it's also available in the jetpack
support libraries that will help decode
that information in the metadata and
give you access to that latitude
longitude information to help you build
your app so we've talked so far about
the three important principles that
we've been building into queue helping
helping users helping protect users data
helping protect your data and giving
better accountability to the user over
who's responsible for putting that data
on the device in order to deliver on
those goals
starting in queue we have to start
restricting the direct raw access to the
underlined file system and reduce using
a feature we're calling scoped storage
let's take a little bit more into what
that means this has changed over the
course of our beta releases this year
beta 1 beta 2 and also in beta 3 what
we're going to be talking about today is
the final design that we're gonna be
shipping in the Q release so I in the Q
release if your app is targeting an
older API level below or before Q you
will see no changes you will continue to
retain full access to the shared storage
device that raw a kernel filesystem
level access however once your
application targets Q its put into this
scoped mode and what this means it no
longer has direct raw file system access
to the SD card one note is you will
continue to receive these package
specific directories you'll continue to
have raw direct access to those
directories these are the ones that sub
mentioned at the very beginning of the
presentation those best practice API is
so context get external files ders
caster's media ders and OB beaders all
of those directories because they have
your package name in them you'll
continue to enjoy full raw file system
access to those it's only outside of
those locations that the kernel will
start returning either a file not found
exception if you're running managed code
or an e perm
Aaron oh if you're running down in
native code instead if you'd like to
interact with content outside of those
package specific directories we're
encouraging to use media store or the
storage access framework instead let's
take a look at example like so when is
it appropriate to use one versus the
other we've talked about both
interchangeably media store is good
forced though strongly typed content
that we talked about images video and
audio but it's not a good fit for other
content types like Word documents Excel
documents or PDF files instead we want
you to launch an intent like the storage
access for America to let the user pick
exactly what content you work with these
intents have been around since the
KitKat release you can call them using
action open document or action create
document and these have two benefits for
you as developers one is it's a whole
lot less code for you to build and
maintain instead of building your own
file picking experience that the user
has to learn when they come into your
application they're now presented with a
single cause a single uniform experience
across all apps when they want to pick
content to work with so write to
contrast media store is a good fit for
those well defined collections images
video and audio
but it's also a media store is limited
to only work with local content that is
built into the device it doesn't offer
any content any access to other storage
locations off the device that's another
powerful feature of the storage access
framework is it gives you it gives the
user the ability to choose to work with
a network file share such as in a small
business environment or a cloud storage
provider um
this is also it's an open platform so
starting in KitKat there was the
document provider API if you find
yourself if you'd like to provide a
place to store content you as a third
party developer you can go build what
are these document providers and appear
in the list right next to any of the
other storage locations that are
available to the user so we think it's
quite powerful and flexible so we've
also heard loud and clear from you as
our developer community when we started
initiating that these changes that
taking away that access it required a
lot of changes on your part and this is
why as we announced a couple weeks ago
in a blog post
we've relaxed we've relaxed the
requirements for the cue release on so
scope storage when you target cue you
have the opportunity to temporarily opt
out in our testing internally the
majority of applications when we enable
scope storage we found that they worked
there's only a small handful of cases
where applications may not be following
our best practices that we found there
were bugs so we hope that as you target
the cue release you'll attempt to keep
those keeps scope storage enabled and we
hope that you'll be able to find that it
just works if you don't if you encounter
bugs we'd like to ask you to do two
things first you can use this manifest
flag to temporarily opt-out and second
please reach out to us and our developer
advocates so that we can understand more
about your use case and make sure that
we can work together to solve it the one
final thing that we want to make really
clear is that this is only temporary
this manifest flag will not work in next
year's major platform release and part
of that is our goal of trying to deliver
on that full message of delivering the
user privacy and security so thank you
for your help with that let's take a
look at an example of how you would use
this a note is that some of these names
have changed over time between the beta
releases what we're looking at on the
slides today are the final attribute and
method names that we'll ship in the
final Q release the names are gonna be
slightly different in the beta 3 release
that was just launched yesterday so here
we're targeting the key release and
using this manifest flag we can
temporarily opt-out we can say we'd like
to go back to the old storage world you
can add this one example that we've
heard from developers is maybe you're
embedding a shared library from another
developer that you don't have the
ability to quickly change its code that
you don't own this might be a good
reason to like add this flag temporarily
but please reach out to us and that
library developer to see if we can work
together to migrate migrate towards best
practices the second code snippet on the
slide here is we recognize that your app
may be running under either of these
modes it may be in the legacy mode or in
the new scoped mode and the method here
on environment lets you check to see
which of those modes your application is
running under one thing that's worth
noting is that on Android we always
preserve the original level of access
you had when your application was first
installed so if you were installed on a
P device were you expected to have full
access to the storage device your app
will continue to have that even after
the user upgrades to the Q device or
after the after they've upgraded your
app so you'll preserve that you'll have
that access you've always had that adds
of when you were first installed this
method is the good way to check to see
which of those states that you're
running under so thankfully thank you
for taking the time to understand more
of our motivation about why we were
making some of these changes we
understand they're hard and hopefully we
can work together to be able to to help
improve the privacy and security of our
users together both Seb and I will be at
the sandbox tomorrow at 1:30 p.m. if you
have any additional questions for us
with that thank you for your time
[Music]